[Music]
on this sunday night
new public health measures in canada's
covet 19 hot spot
alberta tries to stem the tide of
infections
if we had acted earlier we could have
prevented a lot of the illness that i'm
seeing every day now
but restriction resistors put up a fight
american states cancel vaccine orders
will this hurt the president's plan for
hurt immunity
loosening patent protections to spur
vaccine supply
around the world and a belgian farmer
moves the french border
but was it really an accident
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news
there are reports of a shooting at
vancouver's international airport
it happened this afternoon near the
international arrivals section
it's not clear whether it was inside or
outside the airport
all major routes in and out of the area
have been closed
including the sky train to search for
suspects in nearby surrey a burning
vehicle has been found
but the police won't say if any of this
is linked to a recent rise
in gang murders now to the pandemic
tighter restrictions are coming back
into effect in alberta
the kovid 19 hot spot in canada the
province is awash in new infections
as of yesterday the seven day average of
daily new cases is hovering
just below two thousand the number of
active cases per capita
is the highest in the country 568 per
100 000 people
that's more than twice as high as
ontario alberta has also seen some of
the staunchest opposition to public
health measures
aimed at halting the spread of coven 19.
and premier jason kenney is feeling the
heat
from albertans who say the measures go
too far and those who believe
it's too little too late briana carsten
smith has our top story tonight
after thousands of people showed up last
weekend to a packed
mask-less rodeo in rural alberta and
didn't face
any consequences premier jason kenny
promised
future rule breakers would be held
responsible
we will not tolerate those who endanger
the health of their fellow albertans
while the vast majority of people are
doing the right thing
police were given more enforcement power
and encouraged
to use it but on saturday i say alberta
you stay strong
hundreds of protesters attended a rally
outside the whistle stop cafe
led by owner chris scott just days prior
alberta health services had padlocked
his restaurant
after he repeatedly defied public health
orders
that's when he encouraged supporters to
camp out and participate
in what was advertised as the largest
protest the province
has ever seen it ended with scott in
handcuffs
free speech is extremely important and
we respect that
but the pandemic is a huge issue so
it's about trying to meet some real
reasonable middle ground
that allows people to have that
authority of free speech while doing it
in a safe manner
well it looks like the police is
catching us
after the church service there were
arrests in calgary too
police taking two organizers of a church
service into custody
religious services are currently limited
to 15 people in most of alberta
the increased enforcement comes with
alberta's hospitals on the brink
the premier warning if covet cases
continue to climb
the health care system will collapse by
the end of the month
we had acted earlier we could have
essentially prevented a lot of the
illness that i'm seeing every day now er
doctor joe vaiponde has advocated for a
covid zero strategy
and says mixed messaging from the
premier and chief medical officer
of health have contributed to the
numbers the province is recording
but with the new enforcement and the
province's vaccine rollout expanding to
include
anyone over the age of 12 starting
monday vipond believes change
is possible certainly the plateauing of
hospitalizations in icu cases
is reassuring that we're not going to
get
as overwhelmed as say ontario did but
it's still early days and we don't know
where those numbers are going to trend
more restrictions kick in at midnight
with salons and restaurant patios being
closed for three weeks
and if this weekend is any indication
those caught breaking the rules could
now
face consequences brianna karsten smith
global news
manitoba recorded more than 530 new
cases in the past
24 hours one of the highest daily
numbers of the pandemic
tonight the province is ordering classes
to move online in two
hot spot cities as of wednesday in
winnipeg and brandon
all students from kindergarten to grade
12 will learn from home
the order is in place until may 30th in
other parts of the province individual
schools dealing with multiple coven 19
cases
will also be required to switch to
remote learning
manitoba's top doctor says approximately
20 percent of recent cases in the
province
are in school-aged children ontario's
lockdown measures
have helped bring down the number of new
cases somewhat
but there's little relief for health
care workers nurses in the province are
caring for patients with coven 19
and worried they'll bring the virus home
on top of that
they take few days off and for many that
includes
mother's day camille caramelli spoke to
these front line workers about the toll
the pandemic
is taking on them it's okay it's okay
it's a mother's day to celebrate for
andrea jane
a rare day at home with her son pretty
rare
you know even when we do have quiet time
together i'm rattled
she's a registered nurse and like many
in her profession through the pandemic
she says she's been bending nurses are
losing their grip and now nearly broken
we're more than tired we're seeing stuff
that
i'm seeing 40 year old teachers come
into my department
i work in emergency they're coming into
my department
gasping like fish out of water the
registered nurses association of ontario
says
thousands of nurses are not taking
vacation time
and working on their days off to meet
the demand of covet 19. believe it or
not in some units they need to flip
a coin to see okay who is going to
cancel the day tomorrow leading many of
them to take
stress leave or even quit they feel
abandoned
basically a recent poll that surveyed
2600
registered practical nurses across
ontario found
more than half were coping poorly or
extremely poorly over the pandemic
eighty percent reported their workload
had increased
a lot 86 percent said they believed
there was a potential of making
medical errors 90 percent were worried
about bringing covet home to their
families we are short of icu nurses
nurses want to be able to have their
time off the one day or two days a week
nurses are also taking issue with
a wage gap compared to doctors pinning
the blame on bill
124 which only allows a one percent
salary increase per year for nurses we
can't really
collect a bargain but you know we and we
believe that's unconstitutional we are
in the courts
and with nurses appreciation week
beginning monday the registered nurses
association of ontario
is renewing calls for the provincial
government to prioritize
nurses to get their second dose of the
vaccine
calls that have not yet been answered
robin
camille caramalli in toronto thanks
camille world leaders are weighing in on
the idea of temporarily dropping vaccine
patent protections many believe it could
be the key to boosting supply
particularly in developing countries
but the european union is skeptical and
as david aiken reports
canada's prime minister is reluctant to
give an opinion
one way or the other i think it's
very clear that canadians understand
that this
pandemic doesn't end anywhere until it
ends
everywhere prime minister justin trudeau
has a good line when he's asked about
temporarily dropping patent protection
for covet 19 vaccines
but it is not clear if his government
actually supports the idea
or opposes it there are different
perspectives around the table from a
number of different countries and
we need to work towards a consensus the
trudeau government though is under
pressure to step up and
support patent waivers and some of that
pressure is coming from trudeau's own
mps
we've seen vaccine nationalism we've
seen global supply chains
becoming domestic and i think it's
basically been a matter of
every country for itself and fighting
the pandemic marcus polowski was an
emergency room doctor before being
elected in 2019 and
he's one of 70 mps including 30 liberals
that signed a letter to trudeau urging
canada to do what the united states and
some others have done
and declare its support for a temporary
patent waiver
with the hope that new factories can
quickly be built to start making generic
versions
of those brand name coven 19 vaccines
we're not talking
about running shoes or farm equipment
we're talking about a global health
crisis
a planetary pandemic that puts all of us
at risk but many european leaders are
skeptical saying
there are better and faster ways to
boost global vaccine supply notably
by convincing some countries like the us
and the uk
to drop export bans we don't think
in the short term that it's the magic
bullet
but we are ready to engage on this topic
as soon as
a concrete proposal would be put on the
table
and german chancellor angela merkel said
dropping patent waivers
could jeopardize the quality of the
vaccines
i made it clear that i do not believe
that giving away patents is the solution
the world trade organization in
switzerland will take up the matter this
week
david aiken global news ottawa
india could potentially benefit from
waving these patents
that country has opened up vaccinations
to all adults
but many states are running low on
vaccines several regions including
india's capital are now extending
lockdowns
because of a rise in infections today
india recorded more than
400 000 new cases for the fifth
consecutive day
and for the third day in a row more than
four thousand people have died from the
virus
healthcare workers are also being hit
hard by covid19
since the pandemic began at least 860
medics have died
more than 100 in the last month alone
the institute for health metrics and
evaluation
an independent global health research
center estimates india could see nearly
1.5
million deaths from the virus by
september
in the u.s the good news is that covet
19 deaths and hospitalizations are down
the bad news the vaccination rate
dropped last week by 20
in the big picture that's a decrease of
2 million shots a day
some states are opting to cancel
deliveries of the vaccine because some
americans are choosing not to get
vaccinated
as jennifer johnson reports that's
creating a huge
obstacle for the biden administration to
reach herd immunity
by july 4th across america vaccinations
are down 42
since last month vaccine orders are
being canceled by several states
while over 110 million americans are
fully immunized
doctors warn it's still not enough to
achieve herd immunity
now the push is on to reach president
joe biden's summer goal
to finally get the pandemic under
control if we get 70 percent of the
people vaccinated
by the fourth of july namely one single
dose and even more thereafter
you may see blips but if we handle them
well it is unlikely
that you'll see the kind of surge that
we saw in the late fall
and the early winter despite vaccine
hesitancy america is open for business
1.7 million airplane passengers flew on
friday
the highest number since the pandemic
began
restaurants and theme parks are back
open most major league baseball stadiums
are at full capacity
excited to hear like the noise at this
atlanta braves game vaccines were
offered to every ticket holder along
with future tickets for those who rolled
up their sleeves
georgia has one of the lowest
vaccination rates in the country
but businesses desperate to stay open
are offering any incentives they can
we think that more people who have not
yet gotten their vaccine are either
fearful or they just don't have time in
their lives
health experts say the vaccines work and
kova 19 is still killing and
hospitalizing hundreds each day
who refuse to get the shots we have had
not
one case of where a person required
hospitalization
with cope for cova 19 who's been fully
vaccinated
the federal government is spending 250
million dollars to help community
organizations spread information
about vaccine safety to increase
appointments
trusted messengers are being used it
could be sports figures it could be
entertainment figures
it could be clergy or it could be your
family doctor
that's the first thing the second goal
is accessibility and transportation
the biden administration says vaccine
distribution has been so successful
ninety percent of americans now live
within eight kilometers
of a vaccination site jennifer johnson
global news
washington coming up daughters being
buried in afghanistan
after a bombing near school
these are heartbreaking scenes in
afghanistan's capital
families bearing loved ones at least 50
people
mainly female students between the ages
of 11 and 15
were killed when three bombs blew up
near their school
more than a hundred were wounded despite
denying responsibility the taliban is
being blamed for the attack
the gruesome violence underscores fears
that any advancements in women's
rights and education will take a step
back
there has been a second night of
violence between palestinians and
israeli police at a sacred mosque in
jerusalem
police again used stun grenades and
fired rubber bullets to disperse
thousands of worshipers the tension is
growing over the possible eviction of
palestinians from land in east jerusalem
claimed by jewish settlers since 1967.
israel's supreme court has delayed a
hearing over this long-running legal
case
until next week that huge chunk of a
chinese rocket re-entered earth's
atmosphere early this morning
ending the speculation about where
some people were able to catch a glimpse
of the rocket falling back to earth
china's space agency says most of the
rocket burned up upon re-entry and what
little was left crashed down in the
indian ocean
near the maldives but a spokesperson
from nasa says it's clear that china is
failing to meet responsible standards
regarding their space debris
still ahead can summer camps and the
jobs that come with them
be saved
and i'm excited for my mother's day gift
i just hope it's not dogecoin it is
if you were betting elon musk would talk
about dogecoin on saturday night live
you were right well technically his mom
mentioned it first
the billionaire and cryptocurrency
supporter hosted the show last night
dogecoin investors were hoping his snl
appearance would drive up the price
but the opposite happened the meme
inspired currency was trading at around
70 cents on saturday but it dropped down
to 44 cents
today summer camps are a precious part
of childhood for many canadian kids
last year the spread of covet 19 forced
them to close
the pandemic is still here and the third
wave of the virus is gripping much of
the country
as ross lord reports it's left parents
wondering if there's
any hope left for the season
even with vaccination rates rising
families who rely on summer camps don't
know what to expect
once school is out it may not be
possible in person camp but i feel that
they would still do
the virtual village that they did last
year kim bolen's son
josh is a regular at nova scotia's
brigadoon village
which offers a camp for children like
him who live with allergies
jaw says last year's virtual village was
valuable
but it can't compare to gathering in
person they understand how you
feel and
way easier to make friends as camps
across canada await direction from
governments and health authorities
some ontario operators are staying
closed or
reducing services the ymca of greater
toronto said
regretfully we must share that ymca
pinecrest in muskoka
is suspending overnight camp for the
summer of 2021.
in deciding not to open in-person camp
operators of camp tuwingo in huntsville
noted camp age children and staff have
become more vulnerable
and that this is a more potent pandemic
than the one which caused camps to be
closed
last summer we believe it is simply not
worth the risk
the very real risk to any one member of
the tuwingo community
not now not this summer not yet
with precious moments and valuable
summer jobs at stake
others insist they can still make it
work
including this charity run ontario camp
for high-risk youth
we're going to mimic successful camps in
other parts of the world who had
the pre and post-arrival testing symptom
screening cohorting enhanced hygiene
measures
and the staggered use of any communal
spaces in british columbia the majority
of operators have shifted to day camps
hoping there could be overnight programs
later this summer
despite nova scotia's current kovadel
break brigadoon village holds out hope
for in-person camp
if it can be conducted safely it's the
first time that these children have felt
that it that they they haven't felt
alone
and what we're hearing from families now
is my child feels
so alone he says virtual camp will
remain a permanent option
but no one wants camping by laptop to be
the only choice
summer camp is kids colliding into each
other
hugging rolling around on their cabin
floor having a pillow fight
jumping into the lake together and
playing games
it's not virtual and for us we're a
sleep away camp
ongoing kovic compromises as the third
wave hangs on
ross lord global news
france invaded up next a farmer's
accidental conquest
conflicts around the world are rooted in
border disputes but
one land grab in europe is triggering
laughter
rather than anger it's the story of a
cheeky farmer in belgium
his tractor and the legacy of napoleon
redmond shannon has the story
french president emmanuel macron marked
the 200th anniversary of the death of
napoleon bonaparte
napoleon's complex legacy stretches
across the globe
and his famous defeat at waterloo in
1815
literally reshaped france in the
aftermath
stones like these were placed along its
new border
with what is now belgium a frontier that
hasn't budged in
two centuries until this year
he said bonk
as the local belgian mayor explains a
farmer dug up
this stone and moved it two meters into
france
accidentally claiming extra territory
for belgium
it's believed the stone was blocking his
tractor's path
there's no budging it he says it's twice
as deep
as it is high no one would have known or
not for three local history buffs
they recently noticed the stone was out
of place
i lost 2 meters and 29 centimeters to be
precise
says the neighboring french farmer a
forestry worker suggests
the belgian farmer knew exactly what he
was doing
and technically speaking moving the
border
is an act of war
even some of the french villagers say
it's their land
and they want it back
the belgian mayor says do not worry if
the farmer doesn't move the stone back
he'll set up a border commission to make
it happen
after all these markers should symbolize
the end of a battle
not the start of one redmond shannon
global news
it's mother's day and moms come in all
forms so we hope you can celebrate in a
safe way
a happy day to all the mothers on our
team and our own mothers who support us
we leave you tonight with some cups of
kindness the fourth bedford brownies
delivered a special surprise to seniors
in halifax ahead of mother's day
the teacup planters came with a note
that reads you may not be our mother
but you are very special to us i'm robin
gill thank you for watching
donna friesen will be back here tomorrow
good night
[Music]
you